public sénat avec le soutien de mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires vous
présente c'est vous la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la canebière
le vieux port
notre dame de la garde les
indispensables cartes postales de
marseille pourtant c'est dans une autre
ambiance moins célèbres mais aussi
typiquement marseillaise que nous avons
rendez vous ce samedi à quelques
centaines de mètres de la cité
félix-pyat dans le 3e arrondissement
certains marseillais se sont réunis pour
un magelis un mot arabe qui signifie
assemblée
tous les habitants de la cité phocéenne
présent cet après midi sont originaires
du même pays la plupart sont même nés
dans cet archipel du sud de l'océan
indien les comores et le majilis
auxquels ils sont venus participer à un
objectif il s'agit de récolter des fonds
pour créer dans la ville une maison des
comores un lieu qui fera enfin découvrir
cette communauté son histoire sa musique
ses cultures
à la tête de cet événement dit lesley on
ne voit pas assez nous ne connais pas
assez
est ce que nous voulons transmettre les
traditions à nos enfants
transmettre notre culture qui est forte
notre identité qui est forte mais tout
ça dans les valeurs de la république
ces magies leasecom en rien est un
événement typiques de la ville
c'est un fait souvent méconnus du plus
grand nombre mais un marseillais sur dix
seraient d'origine comorienne
en d'autres termes les comoriens
représentera 10% du million d'habitants
que compte la deuxième ville de france
et pourtant ils sont presque invisibles
il faut dire que les comoriens vivent
discrètement le plus souvent au sein
d'une communauté où les valeurs
traditionnelles prix sur
l'individualisme à l'occidentale il
existe même une valeur suprême le chai
où l'honneur du groupe que chacun doit
respecter au risque de devenir un paria
pourtant les plus jeunes prennent de la
distance avec cette culture parfois en
contradiction avec la société française
c'est vous la france vous invite à
plonger dans cette culture comorienne de
marseille avec les acteurs qui les
vivent au quotidien
[Musique]
ma lisa saïd sur willy 34 ans a grandi
dans la cité du plan d'aou un lieu
symbole des quartiers nord en quelques
années la jeune femme est devenue une
figure de la communauté comorienne de
marseille
et si c'est la fameuse place bex là où
se retrouvent d'ailleurs toute la
communauté
en tout cas les hommes c'est un peu la
place publique là haut on apprend tout
ce qui se passe n'a même pas besoin
d'allumer la télé ou de chercher les
enfants il suffit de venir à la place
des kz
marseille pour moi c'est une mosaïque
c'est un carrefour
c'est un lieu de rencontre c'est une
terre d'accueil c'est ce qui fait qu'on
se sent bien ici on se sent chez soi
malizé a choisi de s'engager en
politique
elle a rejoint la majorité municipale
aux côtés de jean claude gaudin la jeune
femme
énarque est vite monté dans la
hiérarchie conseillère municipale elle
est en charge des affaires européennes
et de l'information digital su phares
noirs confession musulmane
en fait vive la république d'origine
comorienne
enfin bref tout est à 1000 en poupe et
qui finalement me définisse un discours
très républicain pour résumer un
engagement m'a lisa pourrait faire
figure de modèle de la méritocratie à la
française ce pourrait être un autre
cliché mais ma lisa revendique son
appartenance à la double culture franco
comorienne et au sein des décideurs de
la cité phocéenne
elle reste une exception sur les huit
mairies d'arrondissement ils ne sont que
deux conseillers municipaux d'origine
comorienne
mais cette singularité devient un outil
pour travailler au quotidien
la jeune femme se met au service des
différentes composantes qui constituent
la population de la ville ce matin par
exemple ma lisa reçoit dans son bureau
cette jeune femme d'origine sénégalaise
et même si elle n'est pas vraiment en
charge du dossier
elle va l'aider à constituer sa demande
dette sociale parce qu'en fait moi ce
que l'on aurait fallu c'est
l'attestation l'attestation il fallait
rappeler et je veux leur dire que je
souhaitais voir ce qu'on peut faire
n'ont eu que la municipalité pour aider
ce travail au plus près de la vie de ses
administrés est devenu une habitude
souvent mal isa est obligé de leur
rappeler qu'elle est une élue de la
république élu par les marseillais pour
les marseillais
et pas seulement pour les comoriens ou
les africains mais eux la considèrent
comme une représentante de leur
communauté
toutes les communautés de manière
générale elle
trouve une certaine facilité à me dire
moi plutôt que mes collègues parce
qu'ils se disent que finalement on
déploie davantage ressemblé donc
davantage se comprendre la parole est
plus libre et donc ils préfèrent
finalement s'adresser à moi y'a pas de
soucis plus demain je rappelle madame et
jovan a alors demandé pour l'attestation
s'il est possible de l incroyable et je
me raccompagner cet engagement de ma
lisa c'est un peu la continuité d'une
histoire familiale au service de la
france
une histoire qui est largement partagé
par de nombreuses familles venues des
comores je retrouvais ça en fait c'est
l'une des médailles comme mon grand-père
à ayew france libre où il a eu bien
aussi la légion d'honneur enfin la
réserve et des de la résistance comme ça
que toute l'histoire a commencé en
france en tout cas pour ma famille s'est
d'ailleurs engagé dans l'armée française
durant la seconde guerre mondiale
s'établit définitivement à marseille en
mon grand père a 14 ans et air
madagascar et c'était la période où on
allait chercher en outre-mer des jeunes
pour venir combattre c'est un peu
finalement le résumé de l'histoire de
l'immigration comorienne en france au
début des années 80 la grand-mère de
mallis a rejoint son époux l'histoire de
sa grand-mère aussi les typiques des
femmes venus des anciennes colonies
d'abord femme de ménage dans les cinémas
elle a continué comme cuisinière dans
les restaurants toutes ces familles qui
arrivait à marseille s'établissent et
dans les quartiers nord c'était pas dans
les quartiers
hu et qu'on connaît ici à marseille
souvent trop sollicité par sa vie
politique mali ça arrive à s'aménager
quelques précieux moments avec ses
enfants
ces instants de vie de famille sont
l'occasion de transmettre à son tour la
culture dans laquelle elle est bercée
depuis sa naissance fait maintenant
[Musique]
trois mois je reprends mes enfants qui
sont aussi bien comment linge et 100
français qui peuvent se sentir aussi
bien à l'aise à moins qu'à paris et que
de toujours refusé ce qui leur running
leur nationalité qu'ils apprennent à
chanter la marseillaise à nous apprendre
et apprennent à chanter l'hymne national
comorien
caïla elle adore les garçons c'est rouge
et c'est quoi le bientôt tu m'avais dit
de faire la dernière fois le gâteau avec
plein de couleurs comment ça s'appelle
une tête de koller voilà qui l'a elle
préfère qu'on fasse le gâteau luigi
couleurs mais bon ça prend tout un après
midi même dans sa cuisine malizé a
besoin d'avoir des saveurs de son
archipel cardamone poivre clous de
girofle des condiments introuvable dans
les commerces de marseille la margarine
que j'utilise pour faire depuis là haut
on fait venir des commandes toutes les
épices qui sont là c'est un peu le plus
tard avec six mois en l'état de dire des
conneries aussi parce que ben sa
cinquième parfum dès qu'on les ouvre
ben on sent le parfum des comores
la cuisine c'est aussi le lieu
privilégié de l'expression de la double
culture de la famille célèbre
indifféremment les fêtes musulmanes et
chrétiennes
ella maillart on se retrouve tout pour
le jour de l'aïd
on se retrouve toutes couleurs et bien
on aurait dit oui mais les comoriennes
elle fait des traditions une ong aussi
françaises
au travers de cette éducation
multiculturelle marisa espère comme de
nombreux comoriens transmettre et faire
rayonner sa culture ici à marseille un
long chemin pour promouvoir une
communauté qui jusqu'à présent s'est
voulu si discrète mais les temps
changent
80 14e foire internationale de marseille
comme chaque année des artistes des
artisans des commerçants du monde entier
se retrouvent au parc chanot pour mettre
en avant des produits de leur pays mais
il a fallu attendre cette édition 2010 8
pour que les comores soit représentée
par un pavillon et c'est manisa qui a
impulsé cette initiative est quand même
un peu dommage que cette première
communauté à marseille nous sommes à
présenter à la fois parce que la force
aussi l'habitude de mentir
[Musique]
des mois
au parc chanot
nous croisons d'un amir saadi un
journaliste comoriens autre figure de la
communauté marseillaise est lui aussi
est très fier que sa culture sortent
enfin du ghetto des quartiers nord pour
s'étaler sur les stores dans ce rôle
international sait aussi le faire
découvrir les comores aux noms comme en
lien à venir découvrir
nos us et coutumes nos repas nos habits
donc ses moyens et ses quel meilleur
moyen que qu'une foire internationale
pour être parmi le monde
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard nous retrouvons
bien à mears a dit sur le vieux port les
décors de carte postale et l'endroit que
ce marathonien a choisi pour terrain
d'entraînement à 41 ans ben amir
collectionne les casquettes journaliste
cameraman pour les médias de son pays
mais aussi manager de l'équipe de
football des comores et entrepreneur
marseillais arrivé à l'âge de 7 ans dans
la cité phocéenne et la grandit sur les
bords de la méditerranée
il se sent appartenir à la deuxième
génération des comoriens de provence
non nous sommes dans les générations où
nous sommes ici nous avons fait nos
études ici nous sommes mariés ici notre
vie est ici et donc on est une
transition avec la génération qui vient
qui elle doit à la fois à se raccrocher
à un pays qui ne connaît pas et nous qui
sommes au milieu qui devront transmettre
on va dire celle enfin le rêve
transmettent les rêves d'un retour au
pays et développer la vie ici à
marseille
cette double injonction qui pourrait
sembler paradoxal benami on a fait un
engagement très concret il s'investit
ici en france développe une entreprise
d'informatique et promeut grâce à son
métier grâce au sport grâce aux médias
les liens économiques et culturels entre
la france et l'archipel
avec ça je commence à filmer un manque
ici voilà c'est mon bordel c'est un
fourre tout mais je me retrouve pendant
près de dix ans avec une poignée d'amis
d'amis relance comores myg un journal
marseillais dédié à la communauté
donc comment max le premier premier
magasin comme moyen compris entre les
deux aussi bien par rapport à la dispora
qu'aux comores qui était un mensuel
était d'un peu de tout par exemple la
patiente était le rôle statut la place
de la femme pas comme comorienne moi je
faisais l'édito on parlait de tucson
politique de sport
l'objectif c'était un trait d'union à
parler à la fois des comores parler des
comoriens du monde
donc moi c'est moyen de me tenir proche
de deux de mes racines de me renseigner
de renseigner les autres aussi j'ai
envie de transmettre l'amour que j'ai
dans mon pays aujourd'hui ben amir a
réuni son métier des nouvelles
technologies et son engagement il a
lancé une web télé regardez aussi bien
par les habitants de l'archipel que par
la diaspora
le nouveau combat de ben amir c'est une
entreprise qu'il vient de créer une
marque d'équipement sportif solidaire
baptisé man parmi ses différents métiers
ben amir est aussi le manager de
l'équipe nationale de foot des comores
alors gratuitement
il va mettre à disposition de la
sélection les maillots qu'il conçoit
mais pour le moment c'est ici à
marseille qu'il fait fabriquer les
équipements d'essai là quand l'équipe de
foot comorienne ce matin sur le port
il a rendez vous avec iph pierre bonny
un de ses fournisseurs dans quelques
semaines l'équipe doit affronter le
maroc pour les qualifications de la
coupe d'afrique des nations au moment où
ma grand-mère en eau
il ya un bon plan
bon j'avais juste au dessus de mandat il
peut sembler surprenant que les couleurs
du maillot d'une équipe africaine se
discute sur le port de marseille mais
pour ben amir cet esprit d'entreprise au
service de son pays et un devoir pour la
communauté comorienne de la cité
phocéenne
ce n'est pas étonnant de d'entrepreneurs
de personnes qui s'engagent pour la je
dirais même connais pas assez nombreux
au prorata de la communauté à marseille
sont pas assez nombreux et
l'entrepreneur le pays tu seras
d'entrepreneurs qui s'impliquent au pays
je pense comme moi aussi a vocation à
développer ce rôle de la diaspora dans
le développement des comores constitue
un grand moteur de la communauté
marseillaise
la société traditionnelle ses valeurs
son organisation se prolonge en france
et organise au sein d'associations le
soutien à l'archipel
nous retrouvons mallis à elle participe
aujourd'hui à une réunion associative
avec les notables de la communauté
en fait on croirait assister à un
conseil des anciens parmi les
participants youssouf sourit le père de
manisa
[Musique]
lors de cette assemblée va se décider
quelles initiatives vont recevoir le
soutien de la communauté
emma lisa est la seule femme à pouvoir
participer à ce niveau de décision
[Musique]
mon mari est lui dans ces vents j'aurais
dépassera par rapport à dos mais le fait
de fruits
mais parfois même avec ces notables les
marques devant les notables les porteurs
d'initiatives viennent donc proposer des
projets associatifs qui recevront un
soutien financier
cette jeune femme par exemple veut
lutter contre la délinquance qui gagne
peu à peu les jeunes de la communauté le
le conseil est séduit par l'initiative
ce projet associatif recevra le soutien
des anciens ce réseau associatif peut
aussi décider des aides qui seront
envoyés aux comores
l'aide financière apportée par la
diaspora sera même trois fois supérieure
au budget de l'état comorien
c'est donc à marseille que se décide
certains investissements dans les
infrastructures du pays
l'association des femmes du la mention
originaire elles peuvent lever des fonds
pour aller ferrand
projet d'adduction d'eau comme à
d'autres associations aux finances et au
sol et on les écoles les centres de
santé les publier au tec tous les
projets finalement on est
installer des structures en commun sera
essentiellement financée par la diaspora
ici de marseille om de fabious de blanc
que ce soit dans l'archipel des comores
ou en provence
le réseau associatif se constitue donc
comme un terrain d'expression privilégié
de la solidarité traditionnelle de la
communauté la savine dans les quartiers
nord de marseille entre les cités se
dresse le petit local de la scène
musicale school
selon certains habitants l'association
serait même le conservatoire du hip hop
marseillais
le groupe iam et psy 4 de la rime le
chanteur soprano sont tous passés par
l'école fondée il ya vingt ans par soli
et mbaye et se lie continue de s'engager
pour les gamins du quartier qu'ils
viennent inonder comme un bon genre les
devoirs à faire
[Musique]
soli et lui aussi l'une des mémoires de
la communauté comorienne de marseille
par le hip hop soul i s'est détaché de
la culture traditionnelle lui a rejoint
un mouvement culturel mondial
cette distance lui permet à sa manière
de faire sortir les comoriens d'une
forme de communautarisme
[Musique]
où
maya une partie de la communauté iq qui
s'est réveillée je dirais et
si consciente que nous pouvons plus
nous clash et raser les murs comme le
faisaient nos parents que cette france
elle est aussi la nôtre pour que les
comoriens de marseille s'éloignent de
leurs traditions et qu'il se décide à
prendre la parole
il a fallu que survienne un événement
tragique la sphère ibrahim ali constitue
le point de départ du réveil de cette
communauté
la naissance d'un mouvement de
revendications et se lie m baye était en
première ligne le 21 février 1995 en
pleine campagne pour les élections
présidentielles des militants du front
national viennent coller des affiches au
carrefour des aygalades dans le 15e
arrondissement
ils font la rencontre du groupe de
hip-hop by weiss qui se réunit
régulièrement dans l'association de soli
et my le jeune ibrahima ly 17 ans
d'origine comorienne ne sortira pas
vivant de la confrontation
il meurt d'une blessure par balle tirée
dans le dos un garçon calme silencieux
jamais un mot de travers
c'était le grand frère driver le e6
cousine voilà après le meurtre d'ibrahim
ali le procès qui a suivi produit un
électrochoc sur la communauté comorienne
mais aussi plus largement sur l'ensemble
de la population composite des
marseillais le militantisme d'extrême
droite
la xénophobie pouvait percuté la
coexistence de ces populations
d'origines diverses et parfois produire
des drames alors régulièrement des élus
marseillais des citoyens des militants
associatifs se regroupent pour
commémorer l'événement lycée
technologique de l'estac dans le 16e
arrondissement 23 ans après les
événements soli mbei se rend dans
l'établissement où ibrahim ali suivait
sa scolarité
une plaque en mémoire du jeune homme va
être apposées sur les murs du lycée
la commémoration de cet événement
constitue au delà de la communauté
comorienne un ciment pour les
populations de marseille la diversité
des origines qui composent les habitants
de la ville la solidarité le
militantisme contre le racisme rassemble
les différentes communautés au sein d'un
même mouvement de revendications et de
du oui la politique de tuer
oui de sa politique peut tuer ce combat
c'est aussi celui de samia ghali
la sénatrice des bouches du rhône milite
depuis 20 ans pour la mémoire du jeune
comorien services et bien qu'une blague
dans le lycée mais ibrahima numérique un
lieu emblématique de la ville de
marseille
imerys un lieu emblématique parce qu'il
est mort -notamment et politiquement
[Applaudissements]
tous les 21 février
je commémore la mort d'ibrahim annick
pas seulement aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
une plaque mais tous les 21 février
depuis 1995 et ça fait 23 ans que à
chaque fois je me rappelle à sa mémoire
et j'essaie de faire rappeler aux autres
la mémoire du brahima libre comme je
n'ai dit c'est un événement dramatique
un événement qui doit plus se reproduire
un événement qui nous a marqués qui nous
à orthez qui nous a choqués cette
mémoire rassemble les élus au delà des
clivages politiques
la sénatrice socialiste samia ghali la
conseillère municipale de droite mallis
aso et lee se retrouvent autour de ce
combat contre la discrimination et plus
de vingt ans après la montée des
populismes dans les démocraties
d'occident redonne une actualité
brûlante à cette mobilisation
on a le sentiment que l'histoire se
répète un peu avec tout ce qui se passe
en europe en france on a le sentiment de
ne pas avoir avancé
on a le sentiment qu'il ya encore plus
de violence qui est un propos de racisme
et je veux des plats mais j'espère que
ce type rassemblement ce type de message
va contribuer à faire changer les choses
en tout cas c'est tout l'objectif les
traditions de la société comorienne d'un
côté le militantisme anti raciste de
l'autre à l'image de la communauté venue
des comores jusque dans la cité
phocéenne mali than est enfermé dans
aucun des dogmatismes habituel qui
fracturent la classe politique française
d'ailleurs la conseillère municipale
élue sur une liste de droite à l'époque
ump passé au mouvement dé constructif
d'agir n'a pas de conflit politique
ouvert avec son père même souffle cadre
d'un parti d'extrême gauche des comores
[Musique]
le dimanche on agrandit la table your la
famille basse d'ailleurs en ce moment ma
lisa prépare une fête familiale qui est
aussi un des évènements principaux de la
vie sociale des comoriens sont grands
mariages
même si depuis plus de 12 ans elle est
mariée à saïd
elle va bientôt organiser cet événement
qui va la hisser au statut de notable de
la communauté comme il faut le mas 2
sous et baby me convient mieux il ya mon
beau père qui lui aussi va pas conviée à
la moitié de la planète ce tempo
politique on voit la politique qu'elle
le présente même dans votre vie privée
dans l'assiette
[Musique]
la fibre politique je l'attends mes
parents puisque cette hausse est et bd
ont mal mais dans les meetings
on m'a menée dans des réunions
associatives politiques et cetera
donc mes parents ont toujours été
fortement engagé militant élu à des
fonctions éminentes et ça bien entendu
un peu entraînés sur moi donc oui j'ai
grandi au biberon là la politique
lorsque youssouf souihli observe le
parcours de sa fille ses études au sein
des grandes écoles
son militantisme au sein du parti
gaulliste puis de centre droit sa
carrière d'élu de la république
le militant communiste comoriens ne peut
pas caché sa fierté il mal ils devaient
fait des larmes en voyant tenir un
discours à fait une elle commence les
délais surprenante puisqu'elle a une
formation des nappes et les nappes comme
l'ont été hollande et les autres
hélas le profil de tout ce qui est un dj
ce prix
son parcours exemplaire et son mandat
municipal fond de ma lisa le porte-voix
de toute une communauté jusque là
invisible dans la vie politique
marseillaise
mon engagement politique
à marseille les partis d'un constat
c'est que tout d'abord on a des
représentants élus dans un territoire
ce n'était pas le reflet de la
population du territoire
donc on l'a voulu aussi porté la voix la
diversité au sein de la politique locale
et on s'est dit aussi qu'on pouvait
apporter notre pierre à l'édifice
participer à la vie de la cité ne pas
être simplement des citoyens silencieux
mais citoyens qui portent une voix qui
apprend la contribution et qui ont les
mêmes compétences que les sommes prévues
à prix de 7000 kilomètres de leur
archipel la famille sourit comme de
nombreux comoriens de marseille
s'impliquent pour bâtir un tissu
associatif très actif
un espace qui leur permet de vivre
pleinement leur culture tout en tissant
un lien fort avec la république
un défi qu'il relève jour après jour
pour sortir la communauté comorienne de
l'anonymat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
public sénat avec le soutien de mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires vous a
présenté c'est vous la france